los rusos bombardean cerca de las
plantas de energía nuclear que hay en
ucrania eeuu prender las alarmas por la
arremetida militar que pone en riesgo la
estabilidad mundial estamos monitoreando
los informes de daños a una instalación
de investigación en harkov el riesgo de
seguridad a corto plazo es bajo pero los
continuos disparos rusos contra las
instalaciones nucleares deben cesar
desde ucrania dicen que han bombardeado
cerca de la central algunas de las
paredes exteriores del edificio
resultaron dañadas por la metralla las
ventanas saltaron por los aires
la parte central de la instalación no ha
sido dañada
pero lo que sucedió alrededor del
instituto es claramente una gran
destrucción
ahora sólo el 4 de marzo una de las
cuatro centrales nucleares la polilla la
mayor de europa cayó en manos rusas
durante los combates con las fuerzas
ucranianas se produjo un incendio en un
edificio del lugar que puso en alerta a
los países y organismos internacionales
algo similar ocurrió en las
instalaciones de chernóbil cerca de la
central hoy desactivada que fue el lugar
del peor desastre nuclear del mundo en
1986 desde el 9 de marzo reportan que no
hay electricidad en esta central aunque
dicen que el sistema de emergencia está
activado para enfriar los reactores la
onu hace un llamado para que todas las
instalaciones sean protegidas
es absoluto es absolutamente urgente que
podamos concluir este acuerdo para la
protección de las instalaciones
nucleares en ucrania seal it is in new
crime mientras se llega a un acuerdo de
cese del fuego con rusia las centrales
nucleares siguen bajo fuego y en peligro